اذا كنتم من محبي الطبيعه ربما عليكم
المرور يوما ما بولايه الاسكا والتخييم
فيها هنا انهار جليديه هائله وحياه بريه
استثنائيه في اكبر الولايات الامريكيه
مساحه يبدو ان الطبيعه محميه من تاثير
البشر
هذه الاراضي الواسعه تبهر وتسحر كل من يمر
بها
اتينا الى هناك كي نرى المناظر الطبيعيه
نسافر الى كل مكان ونتامل هذه الاماكن
انها اخر الولايات الامريكيه التي اردنا
رؤيتها انها اكبر الولايات وفيها تقع اكثر
الغابات واكثرها طبيعه
والاغنمائيا انها حقا جميله
الطبيعه في الاسكا تجذب الاف السياح كل
عام استكشاف هذه المساحات اللا محدوده
الكثير من الوافدين عليها يختارون المنازل
المتنقله او الكرفانات كوسيله للتخييم
والتجول
المنظر الطبيعي لهذا المخيم خلاب حقا مع
وجود هذا الخليج والجبال والانهار
الجليديه فوق الماء ان المكان هنا مذهل
حقا
توجد دببه رماديه والكثير من الاشياء التي
لا يمكنك رؤيتها في اي مكان اخر
التقييم المتناقل في الولايات يوفر للسياح
استكشافها بحريه ويمنحهم الفرصه للمشاركه
الحيوانات البريه حياتهم اليوميه وعدسات
المصورين حاضره لالتقاط مشاهد حياه للنسور
والثعالب والدببه وغيرها من الحيوانات
تعايش مشترك لافت للانظار وعلى مرمى البصر
بين الانسان ومختلف الحيوانات
اعتقد انه يوجد الان كثير من الناس الذين
يريدون تجربه استكشاف الاسكا وبالنسبه لي
الامر لا يزال مده
شا جدا عندما ارى استغراب الناس الذين
ياتون الى هنا واستغربهم بان لدينا مروجا
خضراء واشجرا وارثه الخضره اعتقد ان كثيرا
منهم ما زالوا يعتقدون اننا من سن نعيش في
اكواخ
تمتلك خطا ساحليا يفوق طوله جميع الخطوط
الساحليه لكل الولايات الامريكيه الاخرى
مجتمعه لهذا فان التخييم على شواطئها واحد
من اهم الاسباب التي تدفع السياح للتوافد
اليها ايضا
اثناء التجول في الاسكا فان الاماكن
والمناظر التي تود البقاء فيها والتي تود
رؤيتها غير محدوده الاسكا هي الجنه حقا
للانسان الذي يحب الطبيعه هذه هي الاسكا
حقا
شاركونا ارائكم هل ترغبون في التخييم في
الاسكا يوما ما
[موسيقى]